in this video we're going to talk about
a molecule known as ozone and ozone you
can also view as o3 or three oxygens
bonded this way these dashed lines show
that sometimes the double bond is on
this side sometimes it's on that side
you might recognize that as resonance in
molecular structures or resonance in
bonds but it plays some very interesting
roles it can both protect us
and it can hurt us and to understand
this let's look at this diagram of the
atmosphere
so there's a lot of really interesting
information in this diagram some of it
relevant to this video some of it not
but i encourage you to look at it
there's just all sorts of cool things
how temperature changes as we increase
in altitude
we see the labels of the major layers of
the atmosphere we can compare it to
mount everest and where clouds are but
we we see a few things we have a
troposphere and then above that we have
a stratosphere
now in the stratosphere we see this
thing known as an ozone layer
which is 10 to 20 miles above the
surface of the earth
and ozone in this part of the atmosphere
protects us
how does it protect us well the sun
which most of us consider our friend
that lives 93 million miles away
we know that life wouldn't exist without
the sun most of the energy we have on
this planet is because of the sun
but uv
frequencies from the sun if they aren't
blocked or if they aren't mitigated a
little bit they can cause a lot of
damage they have a lot of energy they
can affect molecules and in particular
they can affect our dna
and if you start messing with dna start
mutating dna that can lead to things
like cancer
and so you could imagine we human beings
and actually most organisms can only
deal with a certain amount of uv light
now if we had no ozone layer a lot of
that uv light would come in unchecked
it's going to get absorbed a little bit
by the various layers of the atmosphere
but it turns out that ozone in
particular is good at protecting us from
uv light so if we didn't have this ozone
layer above us you would see cancer
rates go up we would just get a lot more
uv energy
now an interesting question is how does
this ozone layer form we're not used to
seeing oxygen in this form most of the
oxygen that we see in our atmosphere is
molecular oxygen in the form of two
oxygens which looks
which looks like that well it turns out
that uv light actually helps create the
thing that protects us from uv light
because o2 in the presence of uv can be
broken up and then reformed as ozone
so it's actually the fact that you have
so much uv light up here that it reacts
with oxygen that has raised to the
stratosphere and some of that gets
formed into ozone
now ozone is very reactive and it can be
a little bit delicate it has a very
short half-life it is way less stable
than o2
and so it has to keep getting
replenished in the atmosphere and we
also know that certain chemicals that we
human beings have produced in particular
what's often known as
chlorofluorocarbons and that's just a
fancy way of saying molecules that are
hydrocarbons so a bunch of carbons and
hydrogens that also involve chlorine and
fluorine and these molecules were
generated in industrial applications
things like aerosol sprays used to have
cfcs but it turns out that cfcs will
deplete the ozone layer they'll come up
from our little spray paint cans and
they'll interact with the ozone and they
will deplete it which is not a good
thing once again it will make us all
more susceptible to things like cancer
now everything we've talked about so far
is ozone in the stratosphere but it
turns out that ozone can actually also
form lower in the atmosphere in the
place where we tend to spend our lives
in the troposphere
and when ozone is down there it's
actually a bad thing
and to understand why it might form down
there we need to understand the role
once again that we're playing
nitrous oxides are formed from
automobile exhaust and coal-fired power
plants and when those in the presence of
uv light and what's known as volatile
organic compounds which is just a fancy
way of saying organic compounds that
evaporate very easily and most of these
are naturally produced the vocs but when
you have the uv light in conjunction
with the exhaust from automobiles and
nitrous oxides from coal-fired power
plants it can produce ozone in the lower
atmosphere and ozone as i mentioned is
highly reactive it can damage living
tissue it can damage our respiratory
systems so you don't want ozone around
so it's good in the upper atmosphere and
it is bad in the lower atmosphere
so i will leave you there you got your
primer on ozone and just recognize the
same thing that can help us in one place
can hurt us in another place and the
same thing that it's protecting us from
can actually help create it that uv
light